[MUSIC]
One banana for breakfast, 90 calories.
Lettuce salad and half of piece
of bread for lunch, 300 calories.
Cucumber salad for dinner,
80 calories, total, 470 calories.
That was it for the day.
I spent the most of my middle school
dealing with an eating disorder.
It started from an article I
read about tracking your eating.
Write down everything you've eaten, and
the guilt it creates induces you to
eat less, and less, and less.
Every week I lost a pound, and
this lasted for about six months.
It started during my second year
at a boarding school in the UK.
I was a child with
an extremely low self-esteem.
If you were to meet me then, you would
have seen the smallest girl in the class,
who couldn't speak fluent English,
always hanging out by herself, or
with a very few friends.
Accomplishing my goals and
diet gave me confidence and
hope, that I could become my
ideal self with enough effort.
Living in a boarding school helped
me hide my diet from everyone.
The Boarding Mistress was taking
attendance outside of the canteen every
day, to make sure we all ate.
So I showed up for the attendance, picked
up an apple, and went back to my room.
I enjoyed being in full
control of my weight.
I didn't realize I was entering
a bottomless swamp until it was too late.
I still remember the fear I felt
when I saw the shower drain
filled with my own hair,
that had started to fall off excessively.
I didn't know, then, that the interruption
in my menstrual cycle was a bigger issue.
I didn't know how to let go of my diet.
And my family's decision was to take care
of me at home, instead of using therapies.
The mere idea of having to ask for
help made me feel ashamed.
My family was horrified, though.
My mother made every sacrifice and effort.
She even flew back to Japan with me,
so that I could focus on studies,
friends, anything other
than restricting food.
We suffered through without
sharing it with anyone.
Research by Stanford Medical School shows
that with only six months of family
therapies, 80% of adolescence
anorexia can be reduced.
For me, it took three years to
recover fully, but I was still lucky.
Adolescence anorexia can lead to
problems in hormone imbalance,
bone development, heart disease, brain
damage, and many other complications.
40% of anorexia are chronic.
They come back again.
And suicide attempts after
anorexia can be up to 20%.
As I spoke with my Stanford classmates,
who have gone through similar experience,
and successfully recovered
through therapies,
I started to realize that it doesn't
necessarily have to be this way.
And I started wondering what was causing
the shame, the shame that I was feeling.
Jan Si,
at Stanford Neuroscience Institute, and
many other psychologists define shame
as a self conscious feeling we feel,
when we think we have done
something bad or wrong.
It is similar to guilt in
the way that it's generated,
when we don't meet our standards or norms.
Whether we care more about how other
people see us and feel ashamed, or
we care more about how we
feel about ourselves and
feel guilt,
is dependent on culture context.
But the root cause is the same.
We think we have done something bad or
wrong.
And for some of us,
the mere idea of going to a therapy and
seeking help causes this feeling of shame.
Seeking help is bad because
it's a show of weakness.
But, would you consider someone
going to a gym as physically weak?
We have no problem getting a trainer, and
a self-assessment, and planning a workout.
So how is improving their mental
health through therapies so
different from improving their
physical health through a gym?
I witnessed a similar sense of shame
at my first apartment in Tokyo.
I heard this strange knocking noise
[SOUND] from the floor above,
every night from around ten.
[SOUND] At first,
I thought the family above us was using
some sort of fitness machine,
and made a complaint.
[SOUND] The noise went away for
a few days, but it came back again.
[SOUND] So one night,
I decided to go up and
confront the family myself.
I was getting really annoyed.
As I approached their entrance,
I heard this girl's weeping
voice leaking out of their door.
I still knocked, and I realized
that the source of the noise was
their oldest girl hitting
on their living room wall.
She had develop a symptom of autism
a year into the top rank
elementary school in Japan.
The family was trying to take care of the
daughter themselves, just like my family.
I've had problems, too.
I think you can ask for help.
How I wish I could have
said that on the spot.
Instead, all I did was,
I said that I acknowledged the situation,
and walked off.
And to this date, it is my biggest regret.
I wonder how much pain
I could have removed,
if I could tell them about my own story.
And make them realize that their problems
didn't mean there was something uniquely
wrong with them.
I wonder how supportive I could have been,
if I could explain to them that seeking
help is nothing to be ashamed of.
Do you remember your first day at the GSP?
We were told that nearly half
of the MBA students go and
visit the on campus therapy
during their two years.
This surprised me, and it comforted me.
If I have a problem again,
I can ask for help.
But I know how hard it is,
as you're entering that bottomless swamp,
to take step back and seek for help.
This is why I want you to be there,
open and supportive, when your family and
friends are in need of help.
If you're having an experience
in dealing with mental issues,
I want you to share your story
with your family and friends.
Sharing can remove the stigma
associated with disclosure.
I want you to learn about
the services around you.
If you're a Stanford student,
you can use the on campus therapy for
free, because it's already covered by
the campus health fee we're all paying.
>> [LAUGH]
>> At Stanford, it is seen okay,
or it's even encouraged to seek for
help when we're having problems.
But in many other places,
this is not the case.
Look back at your own community.
Was your family, your friends, or
even your employer, open to the idea
of seeking help for mental issues?
If not, I want you to join me
in becoming the first supporter
of seeking help in your community.
I want you to open the people's
mind to the fact that seeking help
is nothing special,
it's just like going to the gym.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]